d'une frégate couler plusieurs morts
chez les anglais françois mitterrand en
afrique ce soir la côte d'ivoire la
france ne sera pas le gendarme de
l'afrique a dit le chef de l'état
et puis cet attentat ou qu'elle a
échappé l'ambassadeur de france à
beyrouth notre enquête sur les mesures
exceptionnelles de sécurité qui le
protège et un monsieur bonsoir
ils ont donc débarqué c'était prévu ce
n'est pas l'invasion spectaculaire à
laquelle tout le monde attendait de la
part des britanniques aux malouines mais
par petit groupe de commandos depuis
l'aube les troupes anglaises s'infiltre
dans les îles profitant d'une relative
accalmie de la tempête washington
parlait de 1000 soldats britanniques
déjà sur place
la contre attaque argentine semble avoir
été vigoureuse puisque buenos aires a
annoncé tout à l'heure à voir couler une
frégate et bombardé une autre de 14
roquettes
par ailleurs une certitude un
hélicoptère prévu pour le débarquement
s'est abîmé en mer avec à son bord une
vingtaine d'hommes alors comment tout
cela s'est fait patrick lecocq une carte
bah oui depuis la nuit dernière les îles
malouines sont donc l'objet d'une double
attaque de la part des forces
britanniques selon sur le terrain même
des commandos un millier vous le disiez
selon washington les commandos un
millier ont été débarqués certains de
ses commandos avaient pour cible ils ont
des bâtiments militaires des
casernements des postes de commandement
des stockages de munitions
il s'agissait pour ces hommes d'une
mission de harcèlement afin de
désorganiser le dispositif militaire mis
au point par les généraux de buenos
aires d'autres commando déposées soit
par hélicoptère soit par bateau sont eux
ce probablement en ce moment même en
train de baliser des plages pour
permettre un éventuel débarquement et
des emplacements pour le décollage et
l'atterrissage d'avions six arrières
notamment dans la région de fox bay sur
l'île la plus à l'ouest des fal corde
pendant que ses soldats au père est à
terre l'aviation et l'artillerie
embarqués ont pilonné des objectifs
militaires dans la zone de port stanley
ici et à fox b très exactement là en
outre la royal navy fait patrouille et
plusieurs de ses bâtiments dans le
détroit séparant les deux îles cela
signifie que les argentins qui ne
peuvent déjà plus recevoir de renforts
du continent on voit désormais leurs
garnisons coupé en deux une partie à
l'est l'autre partie à l'ouest pour
l'instant
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure nous n'en
sommes pas encore au vrai débarquement
mais les opérations menées aujourd'hui
en sont certainement le prélude sont le
prélude à une opération de plus vaste
envergure
c'est une opération qui coûtera très
cher vous l'avais dit à londres ont
annoncé ce matin la disparition en mer
d'un hélicoptère
cet après midi à buenos aires les
argentins a annoncé eu qu'un avion six
arrières avaient été abattues sur l'île
des malouines et que une frégate
britannique avait été coulé ainsi qu'un
bâtiment une autre frégate aurait été
endommagé ses deux bâtiments se
trouvaient justement dans le détroit
en face defoe hawke's bay au moment où
l'aviation argentine venus du continent
les attaques pour analyser donc le cas
défiant toute modification des
stratégies britannique et argentine le
temps pour nous de nous tourner vers
philippe jacques né à londres on le
visait un petit peu tout à l'heure de
chez vous 2 l'ont donc les informations
arrivent au compte gouttes alors que les
argentins eux ne sont pas avares et
apparemment ça va pas très bien pour les
britanniques nous disent les argentins
ce qui paraît normal
alors qui croire il va écouter ici au
ministère de la défense on se borne à
dire qu'il n'y a aucune information sur
ces allégations argentine en privé on ne
cache pas le fait qu'on n'y croit
absolument pas et on souligne que depuis
le début du conflit des malouines les
communiqués militaires en provenance de
buenos aires se sont montrés je cite
hautement fantaisistes alors en effet
les déclarations officielles donc
disposons ici sont extrêmement laconique
le porte parole se contente de dire que
les opérations se poursuivent et
qu'elles semblent avoir atteint leur
objectif
il devrait y avoir plus tard ce soir je
vous signale une déclaration de ce porte
parole du ministère de la défense est
donc là nous allons prendre on peut être
un petit peu plus alors de source
officieuse donc ce sont des nouvelles
non confirmés nous avons appris que la
plupart des commandos britanniques qui
ont débarqué cette nuit aux malouines
devrait en fait regagner leur navire ne
laissant que quelques groupes qui
établirait des têtes de pont bien
apparemment madame thatcher ne prend pas
beaucoup de risques politiques parce que
si j'en crois le vote aux communes
l'opinion est là tout le monde à rl oui
tout au moins à la grande majorité des
britanniques s'attendait à ce
débarquement
madame thatcher hier aux communes avait
clairement indiqué que c'était désormais
la seule option qui lui était ouverte
après l'échec des négociations à l'onu
alors sitôt l'annoncé officielle du
débarquement nous sommes allés dans un
pop pour
auger les réactions des londoniens un
pop au nom assez spécial puisqu'il
s'appelle le soldat courageux ce prix
vous m'apprenez le débarquement mais je
suis content moi même et personnellement
je trouve qu'on avait trop discuté il
fallait faire quelque chose et le faire
vite la parlotte c'est terminé il
fallait y aller régler le problème pour
de bon c'est un peu hypocrite on attaque
les argentins c'est bien mais pour de
mauvaises raisons
on fait ça au nom de notre empire alors
qu'on n'a rien dit quand les argentins
torturer leurs propres citoyens
on les a même aidé avec des armes avec
des conseils pour leur police et moi ça
me rend malade
j'ai trouvé ça merveilleux simplement
formidable
il fallait le faire il fallait le faire
bien plus tôt ça dure depuis sept
semaines
il aurait fallu débarqué il ya quatre
semaines gachet des vies je pense que
nous allons devoir céder la souveraineté
sur les îles
on ne peut pas garder un rêve colonial
dans l'atlantique sud il y à déjà 450
morts
et dieu sait combien d'autres à venir
c'est un scandale
moi ça m'a rendu heureux mon seul
souhait c'est d'y être
ouais voilà vous allez maintenant voir
des images me dit on qui nous arrive
d'argentine qui ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui mais qui n'ont jamais été
diffusées c'est la télévision argentine
qui nous les transmet elles nous
viennent bien des malouines lors d'un
raid anglais il ya quelques jours le
bilan ce soir est assez lourd pour
reprendre donc tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis trois semaines de part et d'autre
officiellement après trois semaines
quatre semaines d'escarmouches et bien
il y à 45 morts du côté britannique et
61 du côté argentin il s'agit là donc
des bilans officiels des deux capitales
mais il faut y ajouter les 301 disparu
du croiseur argentin général belgrano
vous allez voir avec ce témoignage ce
qu'était la détermination des argentins
il peut voir un bateau puissant que
précis la répression qui s'est apprécié
au valais c'était donc il y a quelques
jours avant le débarquement
d'aujourd'hui nous allons maintenant
prendre le pouls de l'opinion argentine
et la réaction officielle de buenos
aires tels que l'analyse notre envoyé
spécial claudine hier on chante l'hymne
argentin devant la vitrine de l'un des
principaux quotidiens du pays
c'est ici que l'on vient que nouvelle
que l'on commente les communiqué
militaire
cela a duré toute la matinée cela dure
encore
l'attroupement a commencé dès l'annoncé
du débarquement britannique sur la
grande malouines
vers 9 heures du matin
d'abord les esprits se tendent les
communiqué annonce l'arrivée de frégate
anglaise dans le détroit qui coupant de
l'archipel des malouines puis celle
annonce de la contre attaque on apprend
que les navires de la royal navy sont
prises au piège l'entousiasme se
déchaîne lorsque l'état major communique
coup sur coup la destruction d'un
chasseur britanniques puis le
bombardement des unités anglaise par
l'aviation
une frégate en flammes est en train de
couler une autre a été touché par 14
missiles trois autres sont endommagés
affirme le communiqué les ballerines
seront la tombe des anglais dit cet
homme incapable de se maîtriser
impossible de parler avec lui d'ailleurs
avec ses voisins des opérations
militaires de la matinée c'est la colère
qui s'exprime on profère les pires
menaces car les détails dans cette
guerre dit cet homme et ne voulons pas
de prisonniers hier soir pendant une
heure à la télévision devant la presse
sur un ton dramatique le ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur costa
mendez a rejeté sur la grande bretagne
la responsabilité de l'échec des
contacts aux nations unies il a
réaffirmé la volonté des argentins de
négocier à l'audio ou ailleurs il a
avertit également que la guerre serait
inévitable si la grande-bretagne
persistait à vouloir rétablir son
contrôle sur les malouines 9 heures plus
tard la royal navy attaquer la nouvelle
de la taxe britannique de ce matin n'a
surpris personne
la population était prête à la recevoir
tous les journaux avaient annoncé ce
matin l'ordre d'attaquer que madame
thatcher allait communiquer au
commandant en chef de la force navale
britannique
une question se pose néanmoins loin de
ce bruit
loin des conversations passionnées qui
se déroule dans les rues de buenos aires
un mois et demi après l'arrivée des
forces argentines sur les îles malouines
qui campent sur saisine dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles
extrêmement périlleuse soumise depuis
plusieurs jours un bombardement régulier
de la royal navy
cette la question qui se pose est la
suivante combien de temps des soldats
argentins pourront-ils résister à une
attaque et britannique s'il se confirme
que cette attaque britannique et d'une
réelle ampleur
voilà en tout cas de reportages
extrêmement instructif sur la
détermination des deux opinions
publiques
et voilà sur le point sur le théâtre des
opérations on pouvait s'attendre à ce
débarquement nous l'avons dit dès cette
nuit lorsque le souk à terre général de
l'onu est venue annoncée à la télévision
la voix fatiguée l'échec de sa médiation
pour autant les nations unies ne baisse
pas complètement les bras il y à une
demi heure le conseil de sécurité s'est
réuni à new york en séance publique
nous allons maintenant nous tourner vers
washington pour tester avec edwards
alors cette fois la réaction des
collègues
le fait que ronald reagan est improvisé
il ya quelques instants ici à la maison
blanche une réunion du conseil national
de sécurité pour bien que washington
suit l'évolution de ce qui se passe aux
malouines avec une sérieuse inquiétude
en fait on n'a rien pu savoir de ce qui
s'est dit ce matin mais le sentiment
général est que les américains
pourraient bien assez vite se replacer
comme intermédiaire entre buenos aires
et londres
quitte à attendre à ce que l'état de
guerre soient réellement confirmer sur
le terrain entre les deux pays
il faut rappeler en effet que si
washington et londres sont en contact
permanent
la liaison washington buenos aires n'a
jamais été rompu la semaine dernière le
général vernon walters un conseiller du
président reagan a passé trois jours à
buenos aires et il y à quelques instants
le porte-parole de la maison blanche est
sortie du bureau d'euros la régal en
disant simplement ce que font les états
unis et dans le meilleur intérêt de la
paix ce qui est promis en tout cas que
washington même si on attend encore
quelques heures est en train de préparer
quelque chose du côté des européens
cette fois il faut vraisemblement
s'attendre à une déclaration des dix
regrettant la reprise des hostilités
c'est le moins qu'il puisse faire mais
il est aussi très possible que les pays
du marché commun décide de ne pas
renouveler les sanctions économiques
qu'ils avaient pris contre l'argentine à
leur date d'expiration c'est à dire donc
lundi prochain le pape lui à déjeuner
avec les cardinaux argentins et
britanniques à rome ils célébreront
demain une messe commune dans la
basilique saint pierre
enfin deux autres conséquences à cette
nouvelle tournure des événements une
baisse de la livre c'est considérable et
puis la quasi certitude de l'annulation
de la tournée du quinze de france en
argentine début juin annulation à 99 %
de risques a dit le président de la
fédération de rugby en france pas de
commentaire officiel depuis les
premières dépêches alarmantes en
provenance des malouines françois
mitterrand lui-même ce qui est toujours
en afrique s'y est refusé et s'étend à
abidjan en côte d'ivoire que nous allons
le retrouver ce soir son voyage au niger
s'est en effet achevée depuis tout à
l'heure il est dans le pays à plus fort
contingent de coopérants français dans
le tiers-monde
georges bortoli après le niger
pauvre bruno saby désertique
si la côte d'ivoire un climat plus riche
et plus peuplés qu'il fait à françois
mitterrand un accueil inoubliable voici
abidjan où monsieur mitterrand rencontre
un ami de longue date le président
houphouët boigny ami de longue date car
il ya une bonne trentaine d'années que
prochain mitterrand a favorisé la
chanson politique de félix houphouët
boigny qui était alors député français
en même tant qu'homme politique ivoirien
abidjan est une très grande ville de
symbole de ce qu'on appelait le miracle
ivoirien aucun mal donc à trouver parmi
ces deux millions d'habitants
toute la foule nécessaire les autorités
mises à mort y ont mis du leur la
population fait le reste part
francophilie naturel et par goût de la
bête
ce sera donc un sommet de la cordialité
sur fond de danse de tam tam président
de chefs coutumiers en grande tenue
mais ce sera aussi une série de
rencontres politiques du plus haut
intérêt car les ivoiriens sont inquiets
de la récession économique qui les
frappe en plein essor et aussi des
visées américaines et soviétiques en
appeler voilà je pense que vous
souviendra longtemps également du
chapeau présidentielle toujours à
l'étranger 46 personnes massacrées pour
la seule journée d'hier au guatemala
dans le nord ouest du pays en deux jours
ce sont 110 villageois qui ont été
abattus par les commandos et puis à
beyrouth deux violentes explosions tout
à l'heure dans le quartier ouest il y
aurait de très nombreuses victimes
beyrouth où notre confrère france soir
indiquait ce matin que l'ambassade de
france avait échappé il ya quelques
jours un attentat or vous le savez son
prédécesseur louis delamare avait été
abattu il ya huit mois dans de pareilles
circonstances et depuis des mesures de
sécurité exceptionnelles ont été prises
comme ont pu le constater sur place
jacques sébi et bruno cusin
un rapide coup d'oeil sur la terrasse de
la résidence et c'est plus sûr on
redescend très vite vers les pelouse
pour le tour du propriétaire
l'ambassadeur est accompagné d'un garde
et le son chien policier sur le fronton
de la résidence la trace d'une balle
perdue qui a ricoché il ya trois mois
sur la plaque qui rappelle que c'est ici
qu'ils avaient été proclamé
l'indépendance du liban et pendant que
ces commandos de marine font les cent
pas dans le parc
l'ambassadeur des simule tant bien que
mal son inquiétude la raison me dis que
nous sommes dans la sécurité bien sûr le
sentiment ça dépend ça lui prend du
moment là du moment où on se sent moins
sûr qu'à d'autres ou plus en danger qu'à
d'autres mais tout à coup tout éclater
soit les voisins chi palestinian où les
différentes factions qui sont là bas et
qui peut avoir des problèmes entre elles
monsieur l'ambassadeur la présence de
ses soldats à l'intérieur de votre
résidence et surtout un acte politique
car ils ne sont pas nombreux pour vous
défendre ou il s'agit pas d'une défense
centraux du council on parle d'une
forteresse à défendre qui ont des
attaquants c'est pas ça du tout il
s'agit d un effet de dissuasion il
s'agit de une présence morale
extrêmement important et aux fonds vis à
vis de la population française aussi
bien ceux qui vivent dans la résidence
proprement dit que la chancellerie mais
façon générale celui des français c'est
un acte en effet politique dans la
mesure où nous prouvons que la france
est présentée et je dirais ceux des
forces nouvelles compositions défendre
toutes les installations à l heure elle
maintient sa présence c'est pas de
situations comme celle de téhéran
l'ami américain c'est pas ça du tout
mais on ne sait jamais
et le facteur d'inquiétude le plus
important c'est la syrie déjà brouillé
avec la france dont les forces
contrôlent la partie ouest de beyrouth
les syriens et le président hafez
el-assad ont rappelé récemment qu'ils
refusaient que la france occupe où
interviennent dans la sphère libanaise
le président assad fait allusion à un
plan français en disant qu'il ne pense
pas qu'il existe
je peux confirmer qu'il n'y a pas de
plan français pour les présidentielles
et le président syrien a dit
textuellement si la france avait
l'intention de jouer un rôle au liban
nous disons aux français il faut partir
c'est ça s'il y avait un plan français
qui voudraient une intervention le losc
à l'âge peut leur assurer la fin n'a
jamais voulu intervenir au liban ceci
étant elle y est présente elle a pas
intervenir elle existe elle est présente
et le président assad est parfaitement
au courant de cette présence de ces
raisons de ses racines historiques et
aussi de l'appui considérable et de
l'amitié général que porte pas plus de
l'année à la france donc c'est pas ça
qui peut changer
il sait que c'est ainsi et à français
que si elle veut continuer à tenir un
rôle dans cette région du monde
il faut qu'elle dialogue également avec
la série nous saluent ce avant le salon
bien sûr le contraire est un état social
il reste que pour mener à bien sa tâche
monsieur paul marquant et s'entoure de
précautions particulières voitures
blindées et escorte et musclé
quand il franchit le portail de sa
demeure il croise un barrage syrien qui
a un oeil sur la circulation et l'autre
sur le drapeau français
en france un bon sondage pour le présent
république mais un mauvais chiffres pour
son commerce extérieur le sondage
françois riffaud lui donne toujours 54 %
de satisfaits contre 30 % de mécontents
pierre mauroy lui perd 4 points il en
est à 48 contre 34 le mauvais chiffres
le voici 10 milliards de francs de
déficit pour le commerce extérieur en
avril c'est un déficit record
après une légère amélioration en mars la
situation du commerce extérieur devient
donc extrêmement préoccupante de
réaction à l'intervention de jacques
delors hier soir dans l'heure de vérité
sur antenne 2 celle du communiste andré
lajoinie je ne suis pas contre son
triptyque patience solidarité est fort
mais il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
renoncement aux transformations et puis
pour andré bergeron qui l'a dit à nice
le ministre y va un peu fort en se
référant au modèle japonais transformé à
la française cela dit ajoute le leader
de force ouvrière je suis comme lui
convaincu que le problème social plus
importante ces prochaines années sera
celui du financement de la protection
sociale collective politique maintenant
avec la conférence nationale entreprise
du parti socialiste à epinay et lieu
symbolique s'il en est c'est là en c'est
là en effet qu'il y à 11 ans naissait le
ps et c'est là toute la journée 15 cents
délégués se sont retrouvés
serge mr et le ps entend s'appuyer sur
les travailleurs qui ont voté pour lui
en mai et juin 80 il va recruter
informer former des délégués multiplier
ses représentants dans l'entreprise
le parti socialiste est un parti de
masse at on répété avec force
aujourd'hui ici à epinay citoyens dans
l'entreprise les travailleurs doivent
concourir à gagner la bataille
économique et politique a rappelé pierre
mauroy
le parti socialiste doit s'appuyer sur
eux je me donne les déclarations du
président du cnpf sur ce plan là qui
sait aussi bien que vous que la rendons
entre le capitalisme naissant et les
premiers prolétaires elle était avant
tout politique
cette rencontre a même donné naissance
au mouvement ont brillé c'est à dire un
courant politique qui a marqué de
manière décisive la fin du 19e siècle et
tout le xxème siècle par conséquent
c'est dire que le débat politique
guettait une certaine façon il ne sert à
rien de vouloir 20 d'ignorer cette
réalité il convient au contraire
d'accorder le noir au vert
le travailleur doit enfin devenir un
citoyen dans l'entreprise epinay symbole
géographique mais aussi symbole
chronologique c'est en effet le 21 mai
dernier françois mitterrand était
investi président à un public et qu'il
se choisit c'est pierre mauroy comme
premier ministre mais vous allez
l'entendre pas plus qu'hier avec le 10
mai le chef de l'état notre goût pour
l'auto célébration il le dit avec humour
à nos envoyés spéciaux en afrique à
niamey ce matin j'ai pensé à 20 au 21
mai en me disant tu y es mais c'est
l'anniversaire de mon frère jacques
j'ai eu un moyen très graves je n'ai pas
du tout pensé tiens c'est l'anniversaire
de mon investiture le 21 mai 1982 est
pour moi un jour comme les autres
c'est un jour de travail dans
l'accomplissement de ma tâche avec ce
côté particuliers que je me trouve parmi
des amis étrangers et que cela me fait
grand plaisir
c'est vrai qu'après tout ce que je fais
tes mots au niger est un accomplissement
heureux de ce qui s'est passé le 21 mai
1981 disparition à paris d'un opposant
romain l'écrivain deerfield virgile anas
37 ans un ami de paul goma autres
contestataires au régime de monsieur
ceausescu
depuis hier matin on ne sait plus rien
d'eux
virgile tanaz des nouvelles maintenant
de sophia loren elle est toujours en
prison près de naples et elle attend
avec impatience la réponse du président
pertini la demande de grâce comme ses co
détenus elle s'est promenée ce matin
dans la cour de la prison sous les
applaudissements par est-il encore une
jeune femme agressée à belfort mais
cette fois l'agresseur agi à coups de
marteau sa victime n'est pas trop
gravement blessé et puis ce sujet grave
que nous a inspiré un colloque médical
aujourd'hui des chercheurs du monde
entier se sont réunis à paris pour
essayer de comprendre ce qu'était la
fameuse mort subite du nourrisson chaque
année en effet en france 2000 enfants de
moins d'un an meurent de façon
inexpliquée pendant leur sommeil
subitement ses enfants qui paraissent en
bonne santé s'arrête de respirer
alors martine allain roignot a rencontré
des parents qui ont subi cette épreuve
en pleine forme comme celui là
nous n'avons trouvé mort dans son
berceau juste au moment de l'hédonisme
c'est comme s'il est de ciel nous est
tombé sur la tête
les bêtes est en pleine forme nous
avions été chez le pédiatre pour la
visite du premier mois la veille qui
l'avait lisse et un bébé superbe qui qui
respire la santé lendemain était
parfaitement normale s'est endormi tout
à fait normalement jean décédé pendant
son sommeil
le samu est arrivé et nous ont dit qu il
a vécu rien à faire ils nous ont dit que
nous ont demandé si nous acceptions de
faire une autopsie
on accepte l autopsie n a rien trouvé à
l'automne et c'est là qu'ils en ont
conclu que c'est que le syndrome de la
mort subite inexpliquée une licence
étant dire que le bébé dans son sommeil
fait une pause respiratoires supérieures
ou égales ou supérieures à 20 secondes
il suffirait à ce moment là d'être là
simplement de lefranc de le réveiller
peu de temps après ce couple est prouvée
a eu un autre enfant mais cette fois le
petit sébastien ne risque pas de mourir
sitôt la naissance il a été équipé
d'électrodes pour six mois environ qui
vont permettre de le surveiller pendant
son sommeil et de le réveiller s'il
s'arrête de respirer en dormant ces cas
sont rares
deux à trois nourrissons sur mille
seulement sont sujets à ses arrêts
respiratoires que l'on croit dû à un
retard de maturation des centres nerveux
jusqu'à ce jour les recherches n'ont pas
permis de déceler des symptômes
avertisseurs héréditaire ou non mais
sachant que la surveillance évite la
mort et connaissant des cas de récidive
chez des frères et soeurs on surveille
les enfants nés après une mort subite
dans une famille le moniteur d'alarmé
branché à chaque fois que l'enfant dort
enregistre en permanence les rythmes
cardiaques et respiratoires et réveille
le bébé en cas d'arrêt de la respiration
le petit sébastien a déjà eu quatre
alarmes pour arrêt respiratoire
mais grâce à cette surveillance il va
passer sans problème le cap des six mois
difficiles et pourra vivre ensuite
normalement des associations de parents
et de médecins se sont constitués dans
huit villes de france pour informer sur
la mort subite du nourrisson obtenir une
augmentation des recherches le
remboursement des appareils mais surtout
pour aider moralement les parents en
détresse à paris les parents de
l'association port royal tiennent tous
les quinze jours une permanence à
l'hôpital pour aider d'autres parents ce
qui est important pour nous c'est
d'abord c'est d'abord de nous
déculpabiliser nous mêmes et les
déculpabiliser les autres parce que
quand ça nous arrive on al'impression
vraiment de neuf dans un désert que les
gens ne le comprennent pas qu'il il y a
toujours des idées des touches noires
dans les draps clé qui flotte de demers
négligente et c'est pour lutter contre
contre ces choses là qui sont pas
toujours exprimé mais quand que nous
nous sentons que nous ressentons dans
nos familles même dans les familles
proches que nous nous sommes dit qu'ils
que nous étions les seuls à pouvoir à
vouloir en parler sport maintenant
mcenroe forfait pour roland-garros ce
sera son compatriote connor ce qui sera
la tête de série numéro 1 devant lendl
vilas et claire noah sera tête de série
numéro 8
la transat la rochelle la
nouvelle-orléans marc pajot toujours en
tête devant mike birch mais il devra
relâchés aux açores l'un de ses haubans
ayant cassé selon terminer ce journal
sur la pointe des pieds avec un
reportage de georges big ou sur
initiative bien intéressante d'une jeune
compagnie de danse une expérience de
décentralisation qui conduit les
danseurs sous chapiteau sur les routes
de dordogne et de gironde
apparemment dérisoire d'un autre temps
ce chapiteau sur l'un des rares terrains
échapper au béton une cité moderne et
pourtant grâce à lui en une semaine
2000 enfants assisteront souvent pour la
première fois un spectacle de danse
grandeur nature et non réduit aux
dimensions de la télévision
vous allez dans les petites villes de
moins de trente mille habitants
ou même en milieu rural il n'existe pas
sous soluté je pense que justement nous
permet d'aller de trouver son public qui
pour la femme à genève il serait comme
le ballon on n'a rien d'une ivg au
niveau théâtral ça se serait dit on
depuis longtemps et je pense qu'au
niveau de la danse on voit le faire car
c'est au niveau du jeune public pourrait
trouver le clip de l'avenir ce jeune
public
il faut aller à sa rencontre lui parler
des quatre saisons le ballet qu'il va
voir les danseurs de la troupe entre
dans les écoles les anime une quinzaine
de places sont ainsi visité en une
semaine on a pris tous les éléments de
la nature
on a pris à chaque saison
maintenant on tourne côté départs
consultante c'est à la fois un loisir
pour certaines limites et nous tous les
jours on fait ces petits exercices d'une
progression différent plus ou moins
difficiles et à force de le faire qu'on
arrive à ce bien le corps à tenir sera
relevé à faire pratiquer ses terres
il
ce que nous essayons de faire dans notre
action culturelle à epinay c'est de
diffuser des spectacles ayant une
dimension artistique évidente mais des
spectacles de qualité et des spectacles
aussi populaire alors c'est un pari
difficile et la compagnie serge que tel
nous offre ce genre de spectacle par la
qualité
la sincérité de la démarche
de décentralisation de la troupe par la
poésie par l'humour et par l'intelligent
des spectacles qui vous êtes
m
si tous les jours d'épinés alain
gillot-pétré ce temps ça change un peu
ben heureusement je vous l'avais dit
hier hélas demain hélas hélas patrick la
pluie la pluie sur la moitié ouest du
pays regardez notre carte en effet du
vent du nord au sud sur la grande moitié
ouest sic donc le temps sera ou
deviendra très nuageux avec de la pluie
ou d'orage au sud de la loire peut-être
même quelques-uns au nord de la loire et
très progressivement très lentement
quelques éclaircies apparaîtront par les
côtés de fatigue en fin de journée sur
la méditerranée pas de problème c'est
toujours du soleil bien sûr sur lèze
débrouillards le matin quelques
éclaircies l'après midi mais le mauvais
temps viendra lui aussi et dimanche on
retrouvera ce nouvel an sur l'est tandis
qu'à l'ouest ça s'arrangera plus ou
moins tendance orageuse sur la
méditerranée dimanche les températures
pour demain hasseni videmment avec la
pluie ça baisse globalement mais ça
reste tout de même dans les normes
saisonnières
si on ne voit pas jacques sur ces 24
ajaccio 19 à lille 17 sur les côtes de
la manche au 19 à paris 24 au sud-ouest
ce normal ce normal demain samedi 23 mai
trois minutes de soleil en plus lever
6h03 accouché 21h33 une foule de ça
aujourd'hui la relaxe et saint-émile
c'est sainte rita claqué la patronne des
causes désespérées et ses 5 julie qui la
patronne de la corse titi invisible et
corcelles je vous rappelle les titres
essentiels de ce journal les
britanniques ont débarqué aux malouines
par petites grappes de commande au un
hélicoptère s'est abîmé en mort il ya 20
disparus et les argentins annonce avoir
coulé une frégate britannique c'est
hervé clotilde vers 22h50 fera la
synthèse de ses différentes informations
pour le plaisir quand à moi de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20 heures
bonsoir à tous